wer probleme damit hat wie er aussieht
verliert schnell jegliches
selbstwertgefühl nur so ist es zu
erklären dass patricia leute es kann
doch nicht wahr sein die nicht mal mehr
den green screen hin in diesen folgen
leute das geht überhaupt nicht herzen
konsole leute ich weiß dieses volkes
sollte beim ihr hättet mittlerweile die
quarantäne ziemlich heftig ich habe
heute morgen den spiegel geschaut und
hab mir gedacht bruder du brauchst jetzt
wirklich mal ein haar schnell problem
ist natürlich dass alle versorger zu
machen das heißt wenn irgendwie der habe
wie man sich selbst die haare schneiden
kann irgendwelche tipps tutorials kennt
er persönlich da draußen wie man am
besten leuten beibringen haare zu
schneiden dass man zumindest die seiten
von geschäftsregeln die kommentare leute
die hab zum titel schon gesehen wir
ziehen das heute ein neues video rein
und der liste zu den titel ja sehr viele
von euch haben sie dieses video gehört
deswegen mache ich es auch der titel
lautet xxl auf ahmed aus tunesien
braucht 2000 euro von mir hilf mir was
macht dieses m
das perfekt gut im team titel es geht
doch wahrscheinlich wieder um die
ausnutzung von irgendwelchen hilflosen
situation von menschen oder direkt
einmal die probleme die single menschen
unserer heutigen gesellschaft haben es
ist nämlich so falls sie es noch nicht
wusste weil ihr selbst immer der
beziehung war habe ich jetzt mal eine
ganz spannende informationen für euch
hatte
es ist nämlich so dass menschen die
single sind von menschen die in
beziehungen sind nicht gehört werden
können ok sehen wir an dieser situation
wirklich ein ganz dramatisches problem
sie will ihre bedürfnisse artikulieren
aber die anderen können weil sie in der
beziehung sind das akustisch nicht
wahrnehmen die höheren das einfach nicht
nein nein können wir nicht patricia weil
du bist nicht in der beziehung okay
und wenn ich mit leuten die single sind
das ja eh klar suchen sie doch mal auf
tournee sind ehrlich 2000 euro betrüge
das ganze ist voll knicken hier ist
erstmal pärchen abend jetzt ich kann ich
denn dafür dass du keinen freund hast
schau dir deine frage nochmal hier
anmelden nicht so fett werde ich auch
gerne wissen wie viel spaß ihr recht
sind recht patricia höher auf bitte hör
auf mit einer single luft voll zu warten
ist ja ekelhaft wer probleme damit hat
wie er aussieht verrät schnell jegliches
selbstwertgefühl nur so ist es zu
erklären dass patricia leute ist kann
doch nicht wahr sein
ganz ehrlich ich muss ich muss bitte
wenn ich irgendjemanden können bei rtl2
oder filmbruder doch immer diese folgen
produziert wenn ihr jemand kennt bittet
sagt schreibt mir auf instagram hat es
gott gibt mir bescheid sollte es kann
doch nicht sein
jetzt kriegen die nicht mal mehr den
green screen hin in diesem fall geläute
diese art experten anwendung
funktionieren sondern vor allem die gar
keine ahnung von videobearbeitung haben
dass sie so ein ding aufnehmen wurde
eine person vor einem komplett grünen
hintergrund sowie der jetzt gerade ist
sitzt oder steht ja und dann wird in der
videobearbeitung nachher dieser grüne
hintergrund ausgeschnitten das geht so
einfach selbst das machen die nicht mehr
nur so ist es zu erklären dass patricia
sie von ihrer jüngeren schwester so
unverschämt behandeln lässt und sogar
das feld und ich fühle mich allerdings
auch unverschämt fahren muss ich sagen
es kann doch wirklich nicht mehr sein
ohne wird also entweder sitzen bei rtl2
oder bei der gesellschaft die diese
sachen hier produziert leute denen alles
egal ist aber auch wirklich alles oder
sie ist mittlerweile an so einem punkt
wo sie sich selbst dafür verarschen was
da passiert in diesen folgen also sagen
sogar egal ist und hilft das einfach die
queen nicht benutzen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
teamkollege des so weiterentwickeln
menschen
ich finde du solltest als single mensch
auch nicht mehr lebensmittel anpassen
weil wer weiß sollte es gibt dazu noch
keine medizinischen untersuchung aber
möglicherweise könnte single seine
ansteckend sein nachricht bekommen dass
die krankheit hilft okay sie hat noch
beide arme und beine also ein mann der
mich liebt so wie ich bin dem ich
endlich aus dieser unerhörten single
problematik die leute haben
die haben ja alle recht dass sie wieder
aussätzige behandelt weil sie eben
single ist was sie es brauchen an dieser
stelle ist ein mann aus tunesien der sie
um 2000 euro beträgt
[Musik]
oh mein gott da einfach ein man
irgendein mann vollkommen unabhängig
davon wer dieser mann ist welche
qualitäten hat die rauskommt den raum
[Musik]
renndirektor auf der pirsch so können
wir kein pink panther musiker kannst du
dich auf wasser oder hinter haben bist
du nie werde ich weiter mein kaffee
verschüttet juni gefährt alter
betriebsklima ist nicht so entspannt
würde so eine etwas dickere kollege wird
euch einfach und die im dritten und
nennt etwa ein nilpferd ok brauchte sehr
gut siehst du ja tut mir leid dass ich
angehöre habe
geht es überhaupt nicht darauf ein dass
die gerade fährt genannt wurde dekker
dass sie gerade genannt wurde wie diese
tiere mit diesen ewig langen eckzähnen
die in flüssen leben so erinnert mich an
diese eine cholera harry potters team
überzeugt
was ich weiss sowie den man für dich
finden wie tunesien salzburger wir
machen machen einen kleinen kern frauen
ausflugs kleinen girls trip alle anderen
irgendwie so alle kölner gehen irgendwie
in köln im park düsseldorfer mehlis
gehen an die kühe oder so oder frank
vielleicht ein bisschen aus der stadt
raus wir machen ein girls tritt nach
tunesien
und da finden wir jemanden der dich
erpresst sie erstellen und sich dann
schlägt er vor dass hier ein schreiben
soll
kundige frau sucht mann fürs linke was
ist das für ein satz wenn schon so ein
profil auf der platte nur anfangen würde
will ich jetzt sage was sie sagen sollte
es nicht patricia wente motto kundige
frau sucht gleichgesinnten mann fürs
glück und dann auch gleich mal komplett
reingeschossen bei der bildaufnahme und
einfach leute wie jeder mensch weißt
doch dass sachen die auf einem foto
näher an der kamera sind deutlich größer
erscheinen als sie eigentlich sind oder
was machte sie packen erstmal ihren
oberschenkel dort direkt an die kamera
ist kommt dass er komplett aus jeder
proportion herausgeblasen ist jack dass
man ihre kniescheibe sie fünfmal so groß
wie ihr kopf ich kann ich könnte noch
nie hilfe der experten ernst nehmen
leute ich kann euch jetzt hier ist es
nicht so als hätte sie vorher ernst
genommen aber das ist einfach zu groß
wer macht das wer macht das und schaut
sich das kein mensch zwei mal anders das
ist eine fernsehproduktion
kann man da unten rechts in der ecke
sieht man sogar noch wo der green screen
aufhört es ist nicht euer ernst sein
ihre genommen finanzielle probleme echt
ok also wissen später hatte ich ein
bisschen es gibt für euch weil er wieder
sehr viel unterwegs dazwischen war
jetzt ist sie am chatten mit acht mit
aus tunesien den sie über das internet
kennengelernt hat und jetzt bereitet
administriert darauf vor dass sie jetzt
gleich zwei riesen abdrücken darf er
schreibt dass er finanzielle probleme
hat das ist irgendwie schlecht geht
darauf bietet sie ihm hilfe an und
meinte joop will dazu getroffen ist und
erst in meinem land neben männer keine
hefe hat fünf frauen an
aber wir sind ja hier in deutschland
also wie sehr geht genauso weiter der
typ seite wieder dass er keine webcam
hat deswegen brauchen geld von ihren
dann sagt er dass sein bruder irgendwie
unfall hatte und deswegen war noch mal
geld und dann am ende kommen noch einmal
um die ganze sache abzurunden nochmal
zwei experten vor einem nicht genutzten
green screen und da ist der punkt
wirklich erreicht heute wo wir sagen
müssen wir fordern von hilf mir dass ihr
zumindest die green screens tiere
aufnimmt auch benutzt das wäre super und
dann würden wir uns nicht ganz so
schlecht beim zuschauer fühlen danke ich
war in der schule raus leute nie fällt
gangster detektieren für euch
vorgezeichnet video oben cleverkabel
macht's gut passt auf und bleibt gesund
bis zum nächsten mal